tonight we take a closer look at the
security clearance situation involving
the president's son-in-law and senior
advisor correspond to Jillian Turner
reports on what happens now after the
access downgrade for Jared Kushner
nothing that has taken place will affect
the valuable work that Jared is doing
senior officials across the
administration claim Jared Kushner's
foreign policy portfolio isn't in
jeopardy now that he's lost his
top-secret security clearance they also
insist that his efforts to broker a
Mideast peace deal won't be impacted I
can't see any change on the importance
of that or his work on that issue but
former senior national security
officials in the Bush and Obama
administrations tell Fox News Kushner's
downgrade from top secret to just secret
will impact his ability to do his job
they say he'll no longer have access to
the nation's most sensitive information
in addition to being barred from
president Trump's daily intelligence
briefing which often includes key
information for MIDI sources Kirchner
may also be excluded from national
security council meetings in which he's
supposed to play a key role they are
usually conducted at the top-secret
level so they will have to figure out
some kind of workaround to accommodate
mr. Kushner or exclude him from some
portions of some of the meetings Kushner
also won't be able to see top secret
intelligence generated by the CIA and
the NSA information like the real names
locations and methods of American spies
in foreign countries information that
intelligence community insiders refer to
as the crown jewels because of their
extraordinarily high value one senior
national security adviser to President
Bush says the primary job of a foreign
policy adviser is to take a vast
sometimes overwhelming amount of
information and distill it for the
president but now with his access to
information severely limited it's
unclear whether mr. Kushner will still
be able to do this Brett
Jillian thank you